we're gonna have a look at reciprocal
functions now when you think about
fractions right like three-fifths what
is the reciprocal of three-fifths 5/3
right so you know that taking the
reciprocal or something is just looking
at that thing and then saying what's one
divided by that thing right one divided
by 3/5 is like you taught me
5/3 and that's all we're thinking about
but with fact fractions sorry I don't
with fractions with functions there's a
whole bunch of different numbers not
just individual numbers like
three-fifths so we're gonna start off
simple we're gonna start with a nice
linear function like this and what we're
going to do is even though I could give
you the equations I could give you the
algebra for this that's kind of not
really the point what the skill we're
trying to focus on here is the ability
to visually think about things you do
have um you do have like grids and
scales on here to help you you will
leave that in fact if you have your
calculator there that might also be
handy to have nearby but what we're
going to do is we're going to go through
if you have another color that might
make this easier that we're really
useful how do you take a function and
then graph its reciprocal if you turn
the page over we're also going to look
at what happens when you take a function
and you square it you take that function
you multiply by itself okay but we'll
come to that later on in this lesson
let's have a view about reciprocals okay
now what I'm going to do is walk you
through how we can do this in the
simplest way and then I'm going to
summarize and you'll see when I
summarize I'm actually gonna do it in
reverse order you'll see why in a minute
so this is f of X let's actually label
that as such we'll call this guy here y
equals f of X and what I want to work
out is what does y equals 1 on f of X
that's the reciprocal okay
I want to know what does that thing look
like if I know what the original
function looks like okay so the first
thing I'm going to ask you to do is to
look with me at some important values
there's important places on the graph
that I can look and I can draw some
conclusions okay rest do you see one
okay at negative two down here so you
can just read that value off right any
value that you can just read off the
graph negative two I know what the
reciprocal of negative two is can
someone tell me what the reciprocal of
negative two is it
negative 1/2 great and you can see where
negative 1/2 should go if that's
negative 2 that's negative 1 there right
so negative 1/2
I'm going to place there okay so I'm
gonna put them across there okay Rasim
hold your thought I know you've got a
few more thoughts to keep us going
through but I want to get everyone
together okay so if I can just read off
a point like that that's good I notice
there's another point another value I
can just read off straight away here and
figure out the y-values right at that
intercept than Y value is equal to zero
yeah what's the reciprocal of zero the
reciprocal of zero well it's one over
zero but we know that that's undefined
you can't divide by zero breaks okay now
for reasons that will become clear a
little later on what we're going to draw
here at zero is a vertical asymptote
okay so go ahead and draw through a
dotted line because what we're saying is
see that undefined it's like you can't
take the reciprocal neppy you're not
allowed to go there right and what that
means visually is we're going to get a
vertical asymptote and we'll explore a
little more of why that is the shape we
get a little bit later on but for now
that'll do for me okay so we've got this
negative 1/2 we've got this vertical
asymptote here by the way what's the
equation of that vertical asymptote x
equals 2 very good let's just label that
that's important information ok now the
other points that I'm interested in the
interesting values are where does this
graph this graph here when is its Y
value equal to 1 have a look this is
where 2 is right so here's where y
equals 1 is where on the graph what x
value gives me y equals 1 things up here
isn't it over here at that's 2 then 3
then 4 so 3 and x value 3 gives me a
y-value of 1 what's the reciprocal of 1
it's also 1 okay one last important
point and then we'll start thinking our
overall shape you know negative 1
where's negative 1 it's right there do
you see that negative 1 what's the
reciprocal of negative 1
it's also negative once so the
reciprocal goes right through there okay
so what I've got is some important
points the reciprocal function is going
to go through these X's that I've drawn
here and it's going to avoid that
asymptote
okay now one last thing before we can
actually put the picture in when you
have numbers like say let's say 1 over 2
1 over 3 1 over 4 you can see here the
denominator is increasing right as the
denominator gets bigger what happens to
the whole number the whole number gets
smaller right so if you're taking the
reciprocal of something that is
increasing in size the reciprocal is
decreasing in size does that make sense
now have a look over here
see how my Y values are increasing up
and up and up and up right that means
that they're reciprocals over on this
side I've got to go down and down and
down and down they're gonna get smaller
and smaller and smaller okay now as I
have a look at these numbers over here
like 1/4 let's go for like say a tenth
and a hundredth and the thousandth so
you can see these numbers are getting
smaller right but they don't just get
smaller and smaller forever they
actually have a limit that they can't go
past what's the smallest you could
possibly get to thinking about like as a
decimal right a quarter is 0.25 then
you've got 0.1 then 0.01 0.001 you can
see I could I could add a whole lot of
zeros in there right but then there'd
always be like a 1 at the end or
something like that right you can never
actually get to 0
can you right no matter how huge your
denominator is you'll never actually get
0 right so what that means is well I'm
gonna get closer and closer and closer
to 0 but I'll never actually get there
and what's the name of that kind of
shape that's an asymptote right it's
gonna be here at y equals 0 so you can
draw a dotted line across there as well
yeah question
the reciprocal of minus one is minus one
so that's what I'm going through
it's y-values we're thinking about right
it's a y equals minus one here for
example y equals -2 so its reciprocal is
minus 1/2 okay I could pick another
point like for example just to test out
our asymptotes right so here is this
value here this is y equals 2 so what's
its reciprocal gonna be 1/2 which is
down here why we put an X there as well
yeah that's why close to zero so
horizontal line yep okay now we're
almost there I want to just put a little
more information on here to confirm what
I think is going to be happening right
what's this Y value here what Y value I
get on that point of the line that's 1/2
what's the reciprocal of 1/2 its to I'm
going up right which sort of is what I
expect to remember that asymptote that I
drew early on the vertical one you're
like oh look I'm approaching that right
and you can see the same thing happening
in Reverse over here see this value here
what y-value is that negative 1/2 so the
reciprocal of negative 1/2 will be
negative 2 down here okay
I feel like between those X's and those
asymptotes I feel like we've got enough
of a shape here right can you connect
the dots I think we're going to get a
shape a bit like this
there's the left-hand side and I'll do
my best to do the right-hand side okay
now this is a familiar shape this is a
shape which has a name what is this guy
desire blah now we were thinking about
this visually I deliberately did not say
hey guys we're gonna get a hyper blur
out of this because I want you to think
about the features and what you're going
to get out of it at this point now you
can probably work out see this straight
line it's not just any old function this
particular function is X minus 2 right
so this blue function be reciprocal what
you've just worked out is y equals 1
over X minus 2 which you could have
graphed on its own without thinking
about it as reciprocal ok but I want to
point out right we thought about
imported values we thought about where I
would be fenced in to go and then we
said ok well now I'm just gonna join the
dots